bonsoir c'est pour les élections
municipales on vient vous présenter
notre liston depuis début janvier deux à
trois fois par semaine l'équipe de
décidons ensemble à guyancourt toc aux
portes des habitants de la commune la
liste menée par olivier paréja présente
un programme construit lors d'ateliers
la participation l'un des trois grands
axes développés mais l'idée c'est que y
ait un certain nombre de commissions
qu'ils soient ouvertes aux habitants ce
sera complètement transparent et si les
gens sur un sujet précis qui les
intéressent ont envie de donner leur
avis ont envie de construire un projet à
ce moment là ils seront les bienvenus
on fera des commissions la solidarité et
l'écologie sont les deux autres piliers
du programme ce qui a particulièrement
séduit noémie haute vous impliquer dans
la vie associative elle saute le pas de
l'engagement politique pour la première
fois il ya une urgence
climatique dont on parle vraiment
partout et bien il faut vraiment en
prendre conscience
chacun peut faire sa part chez lui au
niveau individuel au niveau de sa
consommation de sa mobilité de plein de
choses les mairies aussi ont un grand
pouvoir de d'agir sur beaucoup de levier
il ya énormément d'investissement qui
sont décidés par les collectivités
locales que ce soit de l'aménagement que
ça soit du transport
que ce soit des espaces verts que ce
soit la protection des étangs de la
minière toutes ces choses là sont quand
même des choses qui sont à la main des
collectivités locales
décidons ensemble à guyancourt poursuit
ses rencontres avec l'aiguillon courtois
prochaine réunion publique le 29 février
à la maison de quartier cosma quatre
autres listes sont déclarés dans cette
commune